hey guys most of the time you just watch  the end product of our videos right two  videos a week no that's one for men's  lifestyle and one for christian  lifestyle but you don't see the behind  the scenes the hard work that goes into  all these videos so today i want to  introduce you to someone special our  head video editor come with me  hey  jump jump jump  yes  i am  i want to introduce you to everybody  everybody  this is joke our head video editor and  i'm so happy that he's in the team hey  thank you daniel hey guys i hope you  enjoy all of my videos that i'm creating  and also thanks for the support  we'll see you guys in the next video  cheers